Pete.
This is really annoying.
>> What's that?
>> Well I'm on google.com/finance and
this is ridiculous.
I have to pinch and
zoom like crazy and look my fingers
take up like half the screen.
How am I supposed to hit a button
that's only ten pixels tall?
>> Yeah, and try and look at that same
site on your TV and it's just as bad.
>> Come on.
People don't actually do
that to themselves do they?
>> It's crazy.
They do.
>> Uh-huh.
>> The mobile market is growing
faster than any other market.
And if you're a web developer and
not building for mobile devices,
you're just going to
lose all of your users.
That's the core concept
behind responsive design.
Make your content work
across any device.